deep learning has been successfully
applied to a complete vision - language
about seeing speech recognition online
advertising logistics many many many
problems there are a few things that are
unique about the application of deep
learning to computer vision about the
status of computer vision in this video
I'll share view some of my observations
about deep learning for computer vision
in the hope that that will help you
better navigate the literature and the
set of ideas out there and how you build
these systems yourself for computer
vision so you can think of most machine
learning problems as falling somewhere
on the spectrum between where you have
relatively little data to where you have
lots of data so for example I think that
today we have a decent amount of data
for speech recognition and these
relative to the complexity of the
problem and even though there are
reasonably large data sets today for
image recognition or image
classification because image recognition
is just a complicated problem to look at
all those pixels and figure out what it
is it feels like even though the online
data sets are quite big you know over a
million images feels like we still wish
we had more data and there are some
problems like object detection where we
have even less data so just as a
reminder image recognition was the
problem of looking at a picture and
telling you is this a cat or not whereas
object detection is looking a picture
and actually you're putting the bounding
boxes so telling you where in the
picture of the objects such as the calls
are as well and so because of the cost
of getting the bounding boxes is just
more expensive to label the objects and
hand the bounding boxes so we tend to
have less data for object detection then
for image recognition and object
detection is something we'll discuss
next week so if you look across a broad
spectrum of machine learning problems
you see on average that when you have a
lot of data you tend to find people get
in a way we're using simpler algorithms
as well as less hand engineering so
there's just less needing to carefully
design features for the problem but
instead you can even join your network
even a simpler architecture and have a
new network just learn whether he wants
to learn when you have a lot of data
whereas in contrast when you don't have
that much data then on average you see
people engaging in more hand engineering
and if you want to be ungenerous you
know you can say they're more hex but I
think when you don't have much data then
hand engineering is that he the best way
to get good performance so when I look
at machine learning applications I think
usually we have the learning algorithm
as two sources of knowledge one source
of knowledge is the label data really
the x-y parents you use for supervised
learning and the second source of
knowledge is the hand engineering and
then lots of ways to hand engineer a
system it can be from carefully hand
designing the features to carefully hand
designing the network architectures to
maybe other components of your system
and so when you don't have much label
data you just have to call more on hand
engineering and so I think computer
vision is trying to learn a really
complex function and it often feels like
we don't have enough data for computer
vision even though data says it getting
bigger and bigger often we just don't
have as much data as we need and this is
why the state of computer vision
historically and even today has relied
more on hand engineering and I think
this is also why the field of computer
vision has developed rather complex
network architectures is because in the
absence of more data the way to get good
performance is to spend more time
architecting or you know fooling around
with the network architecture and in
case you think I'm being derogatory of
Hanna Gary that's not at all my intent
when you don't have enough data and
engineering is a very difficult very
skillful task that requires a lot of
insight and someone done this insightful
and hand engineering will get better
performance and it's a great
contribution to a project to do that
hand engineering when you don't have
enough data it's just when you have loss
of data then I wouldn't spend time at
engineering I would spend time and you
know building up the learning system
instead but I think historically the
field of computer vision has used very
small data sets and so historically the
computer vision literature has relied on
a lot of hand engineering and even
though in the last few years the amount
of data with that computer vision toss
has increased dramatically I think that
that has resulted in a significant
reduction in the amount at hand
engineering that's being done but
there's still a lot of hand engineering
of network architectures and computer
vision which is why you see very
complicated hyper parameter choices in
computer vision more complex than you do
in a lot of other disciplines and in
fact because you usually have smaller
object detection data sets than image
recognition data says when we talk about
object detection that is tossed like
this next week you see that the
algorithms or if you want to be you see
that the algorithms become even more
complex and has even more you know
specialized components
fortunately one thing that helps a lot
when you have little data is transfer
learning and I will say um for the
example from the previous slide of the
ticker Misti neither detection problem
you have so little data that transfer
learning you know will help a lot and so
that's another set of techniques that's
used a lot formally have relatively
little data if you look at the computer
vision literature and look at the set of
ideas out there you also find that
people are really enthusiastic they're
really into doing well on standardized
benchmark data says and on winning
competitions and for computer vision
researchers if you do well on a
benchmark is easier to get the paper
published so there's just a lot of
attention on doing well on these
benchmarks and the positive side of this
is that it helps the whole community
figure out what are the most effective
algorithms but you also see in the
papers people do things that allow you
to do well on a benchmark but that you
wouldn't really use in a production
system that you deploy in an actual
application so here a few tips are doing
well on benchmarks these are things that
I don't myself pretty much ever use if
I'm putting a system into production
that is to actually serve customers but
one is ensembl and what that means is
after you figure out what new Network
you want train several neural networks
independently and average their outputs
so initialize say three or five or seven
your networks randomly and train up all
of these newer networks and then average
their outputs and by the way is
important to average their outputs my
hands don't have urge their weights that
won't work look in your say
seven-year-old networks that have seven
different predictions and average that
and this will cause you to do maybe one
percent better or two percent better or
so it's a little bit better on some
benchmark and this will cause you to do
a little bit better you know maybe
sometimes as much as one or two percent
which can really help win a competition
but because ensemble a means that to
test on each image you might need to run
an image through anywhere from say three
to fifteen different networks we're
quite typical this slows down your
running time by a factor of three to
fifteen or sometimes even more and so
ensemble is one of those tips that
people use for doing world benchmarks
and for winning competitions but that I
think is almost never used in production
to serve your customers I guess unless
you have a huge computational budget and
don't mind burning a lot more of it per
image another thing you see in papers
that really helps on benchmarks is multi
Krum and test time so what I mean by
that is you've seen how you can do data
augmentation and multi crop is a form of
applying data augmentation to your test
image as well so for example let's see
if it can emissions just copy it four
times including two mirror versions
there's a technique called the tenth row
which basically says let's say you take
this central region that drop and run it
through your crossfire and then take
that and prop up a left-hand corner run
for your classifier up in right hand
corner shown in green lower left shown
in yellow lower right shown in orange
and run that through your classifier and
then do the same thing with the mirrored
image right so I'll take the central
crop then take the four corners crops so
that's one central crop here and here
there's four corners crop here and here
and if you add these up that's ten
different crops of the invention so has
the name ten crop and so what you do is
you run these ten images through your
crossfire and then average the results
so if you have the computational budget
you could do this maybe don't need as
many as ten crops you can use a few
crops and this might get you a little
bit better performance in a production
system by production I mean a system
you're deploying for actual users but
this is another technique that is used
much more for doing well on benchmarks
then in actual production systems and
one of the big problems upon something
is that you need to keep all these
different networks around and so that
just takes up a lot more computer memory
for multi crop I guess at least you keep
just one network around so it doesn't
suck up as much memory but it still
slows down your runtime quite a bit so
these are tips you see and research
papers will refer to these tips as well
but I personally do not
tend to use these methods when building
production systems even though they are
great for doing better on benchmarks and
on winning competitions because a lot of
computer vision problems are in a small
data regime others have done a lot of
hand engineering of the network
architectures and a neural network that
works well on one vision problem often
maybe surprisingly but it just often
will work on other vision problems as
well so to build a practical system
often you do well starting off with
someone else's new network architecture
and you can use an open source
implementation impossible because the
open source implementation might have
figured out all the finicky details like
the learning rate to case cajon are the
hyper parameters and finally someone
else might have spent weeks training a
model on half a dozen GPUs and on over a
million images and so by using someone
else's pre-trained model and fine tuning
on your data set you can often get going
much faster on an application but of
course if you have the compute these
horses and the inclination don't let me
stop you from training your own networks
from scratch and in fact if you want to
invent your own computer vision
algorithm that's not that's what you
might have to do so that's it for this
week I hope that seeing a number of
computer vision architectures helps you
get a sense of what works in this week's
throwing exercises you actually learn
another programming framework and use
that to implement resonance so I hope
you enjoyed that program exercise and I
look forward to seeing you next week